the iraqi army is hitting back
it carried out this operation just 90
kilometers north of baghdad it's aiming
to slow the islamist advance towards the
capital
the defence ministry says government
troops killed several militants
but elsewhere the government has
suffered further setbacks
isis fighters have reportedly captured
more towns in anbar province and another
checkpoint on the syrian border
as pressure on baghdad continues to
mount the u.s is intensifying attempts
to find a political solution
in egypt u.s secretary of state john
kerry called for more inclusiveness from
iraq's government he asserted the maliki
government had disenfranchised kurds and
sunnis
if they want
they have an opportunity to choose
leadership that can represent all of
iraq a unity government that brings
people together and focus on isil
but kerry's diplomatic push has already
been called into question shiite iran
which the u.s hoped would back efforts
to stop sunni militants has told
washington to stay out of iraq's
problems
we strongly oppose u.s interference in
iraq's internal affairs
we reject those efforts because we
believe the iraqi government nation and
religious leaders are capable of ending
this edition
and we'll end it god willing
iran the u.s and iraq's government share
the goal of halting the isis sweep
towards baghdad but as they wrangle over
how to do so the islamists continue to
gain ground